what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have to
talk about Spider-Man Noe home that
leaked video going around of Andrew
Garfield the 4K video because a lot has
happened recently and it looks like now
there are pretty much zero concerns that
this video could be fake in fact people
have spent a great deal of time trying
to prove that it is either fake or real
and it looks like people can only come
up with the fact that it is real and
this video and the pictures that go with
it are everywhere right now I mean on
the Jimmy Fallon show Jimmy Fallon was
literally talking to Andrew Garfield
about it on the show now they didn't
show the video on the show and it's kind
of funny that Jimmy actually did say
it's been deleted off the internet but I
actually watched that a few times and if
you watch that and listen carefully
Andrew actually never denies that he's
in the film all he simply claimed was
that the photo is photoshopped however
it looks like thanks to some very
talented fans we have discovered that it
is not photoshopped and the video is not
deep faked and I'll break it all down
and we are going to go in depth in this
video so if you haven't seen the video
now's your chance and if you have seen
it here's your chance to get a very
close-up of it and this is a good time
to bring up the point that if they truly
wanted to manage expectations about
Andrew Garfield not being in no way home
if he truly wasn't in it well they
wouldn't be talking about it especially
on such a huge show like Jimmy Fallon
they wouldn't be joking about it so much
they would just simply say hey no those
are just rumors I'm not in the film but
that's not what they do they joke about
it and if you've seen the video you've
seen how hard Andrew laughs if they
really wanted to convince people he
wasn't in the movie they wouldn't be
talking about it and making jokes about
it but since the video got out and the
photos got out I guess all that you can
do is to make a joke about it now since
the video came out a lot of people have
tried to determine if it was fake or not
and one person claimed to have figured
it out and said that it is deep faked in
fact this person claimed that he himself
made the video and it is a deep fake
video the video isn't long and we'll
watch it right now alright so as you can
see he pretty much just takes what was
already there in the beginning and he
calls it deep fake training and he's got
a bunch of photos and videos of Andrew
Garfield and he puts it on and he tries
to convince people that this is real but
here's the problem with this
he took the photo in the video that were
already there
he's just reverse engineering it he's
not creating it out of nothing
and so if you haven't seen it here's
your chance to kind of see the the video
see the the photo I know I've been
hesitant about posting it but since it's
everywhere I figured it's all right now
final shot without a details and you can
even see the hand right there on the
side and I mean you can get really
really close to this
and it's just not convincing that it's a
deep fake and then he adds the color
correction
yeah this isn't very convincing but I
can see what he was doing trying to
troll everybody and it worked he trolled
a lot of people a lot of people tweeted
at me sent me DMS but I never believed
that this was a deep fake because if you
truly examine this which we're about to
you can tell that it's real it's not
faked and we're about to show you how
this video is coming from Captain sting
and he is an actual visual effects
artist and he breaks the entire thing
down and we're about to watch it right
now okay so we can see that he says here
hey everyone Taryn here going to explain
why the no way home set video is real
and again this is an actual visual
effects artist
as we can see here this work right here
is actually creating something and
putting it in scenes that don't have
that image in it
see we know Spider-Man wasn't really
there in this scene that they're showing
in Spider-Man no way home trailer but he
is adding all of this the other guy
simply reversed engineer it so we can
see him go through this here
and basically he's just showing what the
other guy did
how he reversed engineered it
correcting all the background
yeah which which is something that's
that's pretty cool I mean just by
showing this right here it's very clear
that the other guy the the Deep fake guy
was actually trolling people
I mean we can see everything that he's
doing he did a simple Roto rotoscape
into Andrew's body and separated it
and if you're kind of familiar with
these terms you can kind of tell here
then he recomposed re-added the plate
the background was already clean and he
did the same thing to the face as if he
took it from somewhere else but the
problem is we've seen this photo from
different angles it's not just this
video that we've seen we've seen this
video in two other photos
they showed some fake and crappy wrong
visual effects techniques
and this part's interesting right here
how he kind of makes the body move but
here's about to where here's where it's
about to get really interesting
he's gonna show some very key aspects to
this video that really they really can't
be faked if they are it's like
I mean it's super impressive here but
check this out
who's gonna explain these real world
creases in his abdomen not to mention
they move and then look at the hair it's
all 3D when he turns the hair is 3D that
can't be faked right if you I mean
really
Adam apple moving Shadows on his
shoulders subtle movements and he's
gonna this is the best part to me who's
gonna explain this hand here it's Pizza
Time mother efforts
so that pretty much right there confirms
that this other person who did this deep
fake was blind now there were still some
doubters out there but this person
actually came out and said the person
who made the Deep fake video he came out
and said I trolled you all my deep fake
video is fake he said he did it to prove
a point whatever that point was his
video was fake but the leaked video of
Andrew is real and we also have to
consider the fact that this photo and
the video have been taken down from a
lot of places off of the internet now it
doesn't really seem like they're doing
that much anymore probably due to the
fact that everybody's already seen it
everybody is talking about it I mean
they were talking about it on the Jimmy
Fallon show so they know Jimmy Fallon
even said uh we know what's up do you
know what's up and that's kind of a way
of lightly poking at and making fun of
these leaks that got out now again
obviously Andrew is not going to come
out and say yes I am in the movie that
is not going to happen until we actually
see them in a trailer or in the movie
and even then Andrew probably is still
going to say hey that wasn't me just to
troll people and if I were him that is
definitely what I would do just for the
joke of it so somebody tried to make it
look like it was a deep fake turns out
they were just trolling but something
good that came out of that was the
visual effects artist actually doing the
work to prove that it is indeed real
further proving that the leaked video
that came out was actually a laked video
from the set of Spider-Man no way home
that came out which furthermore proves
that Andrew Garfield is indeed returning
as his Spider-Man in Spider-Man no way
home and that also pretty much confirms
that Toby Maguire is also returning as
his Spider-Man from the Sam Rhema
Universe in Spider-Man no way home both
are returning like we've been saying for
a pretty long time now again if they
don't I'm just gonna be completely and
utterly in shock and I won't really know
what to say but I truly believe that
they both are going to be in the film
I've been told they're going to be in
the film and we just have so much
evidence at this point in time and now
since this video is pretty much
confirmed to be real if I had any sliver
of doubt it's gone But be sure to let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
always follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf